hey youtubers is Charlie and next week
Marvel is airing a super special first
look at footage from Avengers 2 age of
Ultron so for my Marvel movie video
today I wanted to talk a little bit
about the story and the things we've
learned so far and how it's going to
inform phase 3 I will be posting a full
breakdown to that Avengers 2 footage
whatever posts next week so be sure to
subscribe to get that video it's gonna
be amazing
so here's some specific details about
what's going on next week the special is
going to air on ABC Tuesday March 18th
at 8 p.m. Eastern Time during a special
called marvel assembling a universe it's
a special they're airing instead of a
new episode of agents of shield and it's
meant to be a deep look into the Marvel
Universe that integrates all the movies
and the TV shows remember there are
actually a few new TV shows coming in
the next couple of years basically how
it integrates everything so that they
can tell one large story across several
movies and TV shows there's going to be
footage from age of Ultron as well as
Captain America Winter Soldier and
guardians of the galaxy I'll talk about
everything but mostly my breakdown will
focus on age of Ultron since this will
be the first footage we've officially
seen there have been a few pictures and
clips of them actually filming the movie
but they're really low quality right now
the only real footage we've seen from
age of Ultron is the announcement teaser
from Comic Con and that wasn't real
footage it was really just originally an
image of Ultron
since then we've learned who most of the
new characters will be including vision
voiced by Paul Bettany who also does the
voice of Jarvis there will probably be a
motion capture element to his
performance as well as James Spader
who's voicing Ultron then there's two
more major additions including
Quicksilver played by Aaron Johnson and
Scarlet Witch played by Elizabeth Olsen
even if they aren't featured in the
video next Tuesday they are rumored to
be in one of the Captain America Winter
Soldier post-credit scenes so we will
get to see what their powers look like
on screen isn't it funny how x-men Days
of Future past is featuring the
Quicksilver character in this really big
way but he's appearing for the first
time at the end of a Marvel movie
I wonder how Bryan Singer and Fox feel
about that somatically age of Ultron is
the beginning of a new age for
superheroes and villains in the Marvel
Universe think of it as the age of
miracles I would call it the age of
mutants but since Fox legally has the
rights to the x-men franchise only they
get to use that term in their movies so
Marvel is substituting the term miracles
too broadly imply that magic and other
strange abilities are going
play a huge role going forward it's all
really paving the way so that they can
tell the Infinity Gauntlet storyline in
a realistic way or semi realistic an
early review for Captain America Winter
Soldier included some spoilers for two
separate post-credits scenes so turn the
volume down right now if you don't want
to know anything about that
so one of them was just a Winter Soldier
specific scene but the other
post-credits clip was for Avengers age
of Ultron in addition to Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch
it features Baron von Strucker he's
keeping them locked in an underground
cell and the scene is really just a
quick shot of Quicksilver bouncing
around the walls at SuperSpeed and
Scarlet Witch levitating objects in the
air von Strucker has the only dialogue
and he says the age of miracles is upon
us okay you can turn the volume back up
suppose over so let's talk a little bit
about phase 3 because Avengers 2 is
actually gonna be the last movie before
ant-man which is the official beginning
of the next phase of movies Kevin Feige
was quoted a couple of years ago as
saying in the broad sense that phase 3
represented magic opening the door to
all the dr. strange rumors that you may
have been hearing recently that movie
hasn't officially been announced but
Marvel still has to untitled movies
scheduled for phase 3 in addition to Ant
Man Thor 3 Captain America 3 and
Avengers 3 in keeping with the general
theme of magic obviously Doctor Strange
would be a natural fit for one of those
untitled movies there's also the
possibility of a female-driven movie
like Black Widow Marvel has said that
they've got one war in development but
nothing has been officially announced
unofficially the rumor is that it's a
Miss Marvel movie but Black Panther is
also another possibility for that
untitled film so now let's talk a little
bit about the plot of Avengers 2 based
on some of the comments that Joss Whedon
has made and some of the
behind-the-scenes images we've seen
after the initial comic-con announcement
last year Whedon talked about the
evolution of Ultron as a character
during the movie they're going to change
his appearance so the final version
won't look like the comic book version
the origin of the character is different
too I haven't done an ant-man video yet
but Hank Pym in the movie will not be
his creator like he is in the comic
books in age of Ultron he's going to
evolve from a military AI version of
Jarvis so essentially Tony Stark is
going to be his father Whedon just said
that they were doing it this way because
they wanted Ultron to flow from things
that they had already developed in the
Cinematic Universe
and they've been developing the Tony
Stark character since 2008 so on paper
he shares a lot of similarities with
Hank Pym so it kind of works but if
you've read the comics especially
recently with Marvel's Avengers AI
series Hank Pym seems like he's way more
unstable than Tony Stark since stark
tech will give birth to Ultron you can
kind of understand why now the voice of
Jarvis Paul Bettany is the logical
choice to play the vision if you're not
familiar he's an Android that's created
by Ultron to help him defeat the
Avengers it's going to be Tony Stark
giving birth to all Tron giving birth to
the vision so get excited like Baron von
Strucker said this is the age of
miracles so now that I dropped all that
info on you let me know what are you
most excited to see especially with this
new footage you know Quicksilver Scarlet
Witch Ultron the vision like I said I'll
be posting a full breakdown to that new
footage next week after post be sure to
subscribe to get it and be sure to send
me all your suggestions for future
Marvel movie videos that you want me to
do right now click here to learn all
about my miss Marvel agents of shield
theories and click here to learn about
my top picks for the Doctor Strange
movie thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you